hi everyone I'm really excited to
introduce my friend Carla Diana she's a
fellow human robot interaction designer
she teaches at university of
pennsylvania's integrated design program
innovative program product design
program like I have and she also worked
really closely with a professor Andrea
Tomas who's originally at Georgia Tech
and now at UT Austin on designing their
robot platform Simon Simon great name
carla has this really special dual
citizenship she does academics like some
of us but also has done a lot of work in
the commercial design space she has a
work experience and as smart party sign
to being a lot of things that we think
of his consumer products and so I think
she brings this like wonderful
perspective of bear which she really has
been both in the academic and commercial
world and she's also really well known
for her popular writing on technology
products I actually found out recently
this goes back pretty far she used to
review a consumer products for a good
housekeeping but she also does a lot of
writing for popular science and New York
Times and helps other people understand
what it is that we are doing so without
further ado everyone Carla Dana Wendy um
so I'm excited to be here I'm going to
take you on a little bit of a wild ride
like Wendy said I do straddle both
academia and Industry and I bring
knowledge from one to feed the other
ideally lately I've been calling myself
a maker future is because I don't
believe in writing based on things that
I have an experience so I try to force
myself to do a lot of hands-on
experiments so that I'm actually in
touch with the technology that I'm
writing about and understand it from a
in a visceral way so I've worked for a
number of firms a decade ago i was here
at frog design in the bay area more
recently i was at smart design in the
New York City office I mean many people
are familiar with smart
for this from this oxxo peeler which I
know some of you have in your kitchens
but a lot of people also don't realize
that smart does a lot of other things my
focus there and the reason I went there
was because they had a culture of making
and physical things and I specifically
focused on designing physical things
that had some kind of digital behavior
digital component because what really
excites me is the idea of bringing a
physical thing to life because of
program behaviors and while I was it
smart I realized that there were a lot
of other people who are interested in
this aspect of product design as well
and because it was such a new product
new area we were really pioneering and
so I started a lab within the firm it's
called the smart interaction lab that
would allow designers engineers and
other folks working there to take time
in between client projects to work on
exploratory projects as Wendy mentioned
I'm going to skip this one because I'm
going to talk about this later as when
he mentioned I'm also part of the
faculty of the integrated product design
program at the University of
Pennsylvania I've created a couple of
the university's first and only courses
on designing smart objects so this is an
example of a student project bike I
evanston called Palou glow and I also do
enjoy really distilling the work of me
and my colleagues into a way that helps
share what is coming in the future with
a larger general audience and so I've
written a number of essays about
robotics in our everyday lives more
recently one that's in this month's
popular science it's called don't blame
the robots blame us it's actually
available online now and what I was
discussing here was disconnect between
what people envision as autonomous
driving which is instead of what's
really assistive driving and how design
is key to helping
people understand what it is that the
robot sees as opposed to what their
mental model is which is to get in a car
that is just going to take off and do
everything for you so the first part of
my talk I wanted to share a little bit
of my work in this realm of social
robotics and my work in that area has
been around embodiment and thinking
about how form communicates so some of
you may be familiar with Leonardo from
MIT which was a social robot the whole
for those I think I'm speaking to an
audience very familiar with social
robotics but for those of you who may
not be that the actual goal of these
projects are to study how we might
interact with machines in a human way
how we might gesture the way I'm
gesturing hen machine and object have
the Machine gesture back to us and so
what I worked on I show Leonardo because
it's a project that dr. Andrea tomoz was
working on at MIT Media Lab that was a
precursor to Simon so what she had
learned was that you know with the
Leonardo project the team engaged will
vinton studios a very high quality stop
motion animation to come up with the
embodiment and it's got a leather knows
it's got these amazing lips and yak hair
it's got these these fingers if you've
ever seen it it's at the MIT museum
these the fingers little wrinkles in
there you just want to touch them and
squeeze it and but you know what what
the team found was that this fell into
what roboticist commonly called the
uncanny valley where it seemed like it
was really alive and children even were
you know running screaming from the room
because it was a bit frightening so
Andrew put out a call to work with
designer and I wound up winning the job
to work with her and she said she was
going to start a new social robot
platform and what she wanted to do was
be really careful to manage expectations
so we sat down together and we were a
core team of three myself dr. tomasz and
Jonathan Holmes was a mechanical
engineer and you know it was really
lovely was being able to work from day
one together and really think about well
you know should it have years does it
not have ears is it is it hair or you
know and really studying some of the
other robots that existed in the world
and looking at what people's perceptions
were of those features and so the final
result is what you see here which is
Simon and Simon is specifically designed
to be a social robotics platform for
research to kind of in as a designer I
really think of this as you know pushing
the very boundary of interaction and
seeing you know how can we have the most
interactive machine possible so these
are some of Simon's various expressions
looking coy or looking bored or looking
like he's listening and here's a short
video that just kind of shows you a
little bit of one interaction in this
video you'll see Simon listening there
this was taken from the chi conference I
think in 2012 and Simon is listening and
he's parsing a sentence to hear what the
color is he's doing a color sorting
exercise
so I put subtitles on this it at the
conference the sound was a bit loud so
someone says Simon where does this go
Simon Says I don't know and she says it
goes in the green bin so Simon knows to
parse the sentence this goes in the
blank and pull out the word green so
that the next time the cameras detect
the the most pixels that are green Simon
will know that it goes in the green bin
so that's just one piece of research
this is a a giant team with many
artificial intelligence PhD students
working on different aspects of the
behavior there's a lot around social
interactions around maintaining gaze
around turn-taking so this is dr. tomoz
from her a TEDx talk where she is
talking a little bit about the benefit
of this embodiment it's like when the
robot just uses words to ask a
clarifying question in the green object
17 inches from the table edge a flower
pot okay well I'm not sure which of
these two objects is 17 inches from the
table top I probably have to get out my
tape measure to really answer that
question but let's see how different it
is when we let the robot use gestures as
well so now instead of a complicated
object description she can just point is
this the flower pot yes it is and it was
a much more reasonable way to ask that
question so that's kind of showcases
some of the interactive benefits that we
get from having a body man this is curry
that was actually the cousin to Simon so
I love when I get a call from dr. tomoz
because I get asked things like can we
make a cousin and well what is a cousin
are they what does the family or that
are they going to be in the room at the
same time so this is curie actually this
is actually just a boot up sequence but
i love this because i feel like it's
robot tai chi
this particular robot the voltage robots
were just upper torso humanoids we've
also had we've had done lots of work we
had a big workshop around the connecting
the top of the torso to the base this
one's on a mobile base there are lots of
really really really juicy permanent
interesting challenges for me as a
designer to think about what the
implications are for social interaction
just by the form alone so and there's
this interesting axis where you were
you're trying you can ask how many q's
do I need to produce a social reaction
out of someone right and obviously will
you start out by saying with that
leonardo was sort of too far on the real
lot real side and you can imagine
something that's even further on the
abstract side of just a pair of eyes
that which i think the eyes are doing a
lot of the work here yeah so wondering
how did you come to the exact sort of
level of fidelity that came here like
why here versus slightly more realistic
or slightly less realistic yeah that's a
really great question and today we're
dr. Claude really believes these
projects and I in particular these are
my first robots and I leaned on her
history and knowledge and you know to
what and she had had been coming from
the Leonardo project with certain
criteria around the importance of head
nodding around the importance of
gesturing with the arms around learnings
around the facial expressions and then
there were some places where I was
pushing or pulling which I'll talk about
next but so it's really a legacy from
the lily & Order project we're actually
working together now and I don't have
any of these slides on a pretty exciting
new project that is very much abstracted
very much a camera on a stick and how
can we
so that I know that's it that's a that's
a great question i came to it as a
designer with some liberties but with a
lot of criteria so but one of the
liberties that i took was well one of
them was to have these giant ears
because Andrea had said you know we do
know that as humans we take a lot of
cues from animals and animals are very
particularly expressive with their ears
and that was one thing that they had
learned in the Leonardo project was that
the ears were able to communicate a lot
in a short hand abstract way that's not
even necessarily human anymore right
it's kind of like human-animal
interaction so so I said well let's you
know let's let's exaggerate these ears
and and then you know we didn't have
part of the criteria was was just to
simply have these ears with with motion
and I said well you know can we also had
lights in there and would that cost much
more and just to see if we could have
this additional mode of expression and
you know we costed it out with
engineered sure and what happened was
this kind of really amazing moment where
the first time I met the robot it had
been assembled and certainly I knew and
I had seen simulations I knew exactly
what was going to do but there was this
moment the kind of gave me goosebumps
when I handed Simon this flower and the
ears turn the same color as the flower
because I was doing the color exercise
now of course it was all scripted and
but I had this moment of goosebumps when
I felt like he knows what I'm thinking
he knows exactly what I want him to do
and he's looking where I want him to
look and and and I realized so as a
designer coming from this background of
Industry and working on everyday things
like printers and medical devices I felt
like that's a really really powerful
moment a lot of my colleagues in the
design world felt like this was really
crazy work
that I had been doing like yeah the your
robot projects yeah that's that's great
that really has nothing to do with what
we do as professional designers with
real things I felt like it has
everything to do with what we do and I
realized that what was exciting to me
was being able to extrapolate moments
from these design projects and not
necessarily having an object that has a
head and eyeballs and but you know could
we just could we just take this color
moment and have you know a microphone
that turned to the color to let me know
when I've said a word that I didn't
programmed it to flag for me so I got
asked by an editor at The Times who had
heard me talk about this passionate idea
of robotics and everyday products who
asked me to do a essay for the sunday
review and you know in the essay I wrote
a little bit about this vision of where
you know the the icy robotics really
being coming a very big part of everyday
life but you know my vision is we will
have abstracted moments just short
moments that are only appropriate for
the context at hand and as part of this
essay the editor sending I think it'd be
great if we could do a slideshow so I'm
going to share a little bit of the
slideshow which you'll see is admittedly
tongue-in-cheek
[Music]
I'm Carla and this is a day in the near
future another Monday morning my lamp
has just gone from dim too bright I try
to turn over but it rotates to follow me
I stumbled into the bathroom I brush one
side for a while this is the toothbrush
vibrates so I know it's time to switch
to the other side now I'm really awake
the bathroom mirror says nice job on
your weight but your heart rate is a
little higher than yesterday as I had to
work my bike confirms my appointment on
our way to Ted's office yes when it's
time to turn my handlebar vibrates and
my jacket lights up to signal a left
turn at the meeting I draw some sketches
with my memory pen when we're done it
emails my notes to my colleagues back at
home the door recognizes me the lights
turn on the stereo starts playing and my
3d printer whistles to let me know the
dog toy I downloaded earlier for Roo is
ready now it's time for dinner my
counter top sous-chef checks my favorite
recipes and wirelessly queries the
fridge we have ingredients to make
roasted salmon or pumpkin result all
let's do the salmon I say after dinner
my partner Mike and I bring our dishes
to the sink I say okay start cleaning
and the faucet squirts soap and water at
the dishes while we head off to relax
with our favorite movie back to the
future
so it gets kind of out of hand towards
the end there but you know like for
example just having the lamp that has a
gaze on you is the kind of thing I think
is really interesting and I realize that
I want to spend my career exploring so
you know what I try to do when working
with clients and working in my own
studio on sort of self initiated
projects is think about expressive
objects how can we use light sound and
motion to have this object that has a
continuous conversation with us so I do
a lot of this kind of stuff now with
clients which is interesting that
there's more and more respect for the
value of you know what's the difference
between having blue lights chasing or
having green lights pulsing this is a
quick project that I did for a bar in
New York where there was this old
English wooden bar and there's something
that happens when the chef has a plate
that's ready and there's usually like a
bell or a light that goes off so instead
of doing that what I did was I program
this animation to have the icons for the
bar the bars called play and they have
this I concerts like I nose and lips in
a mouth and so I have those icons that
do this like crazy licking sniffing
animation when the plate is ready so
that the server's know what's going on
but the people who are at the bar just
kind of see this crazy animation
happening it's just a subtle quick
interaction it's the only thing that it
needs to do this is another project
involving light so these are some of my
colleagues in conjunction with the
interaction lab at smart we thought
about creating a beacon we were always
thinking we had a very big open plan
studio which is really wonderful for
serendipitous conversations but terrible
if you want to have heads down focused
work so on what we did was we use the
geometry another thing I try to think a
lot about is how does the actual
geometry of the form relate to the
information and we created this
interface that would have four states
where you could let people know if your
heads down busy if you are available for
brainstorming if you're going to be out
of the office or a fewer
out taking a break for lunch or coffee
and you just twist the cube and the
color changes so you have this beacon at
your desk that can be viewed at a
distance and then the other aspect of it
is that it's connected via Wi-Fi so at
the time we had three studios in three
different locations so this allowed the
cube to actually kind of act on your
behalf and communicate with the larger
company and let everyone know oh hey
this person is available or you know if
you saw that everyone in the London
office with super heads down you might
say okay well maybe maybe there's
something going on there we should
actually leave them alone so another big
project that I worked on at smart I led
the interaction effort for the neato
Robo vac before this time really the the
leading company for robotic vacuums was
was the iRobot Roomba and neato has a
laser vision system so this was our
original vision and I worked very hard
on creating a personality so um then and
there's a vision for the neato that it
would have this LED matrix the idea
being you could see it from across the
room and we would also have facial
expressions that would communicate
various moments so I really focused on
the emotional moments that you have with
a vacuum cleaner like what are the what
does the vacuum cleaner actually feel so
I mapped out different parts of the
interaction you know for example when
it's done cleaning it's kind of
triumphant and heading back to its base
and so it can do it can celebrate if
it's stuck under the couch it is a
moment of distress so how do we you know
communicate that and so what I did is
when I plotted out the interaction I
listed each moment and tried to map out
how I could translate that moment from
the robots emotions into something that
a human would understand and sometimes
it was English words and we had kind of
a
we had a strategy for when we needed
words and when we just needed facial
expressions or iconography and then
there was also a sound associated with
each of those and so I want to show you
some of the sounds like hired a composer
named Scooby Lepofsky and we defined
what the personality of the robot should
be we did kind of a scope of should it
be quiet like a hotel maid should be
like a bartender we came someplace in
the middle so here's how the robot
communicates this is what happened when
it says that cleaning has begun and this
is claiming his done and this is via one
benefit of the neato is I was working
closely with their robotics engineers
and I said well if it's doing a laser
vision can it recognize a person and at
the time they said well we think it
could so I choreographed this moment
when the robot would say oh hello and
then actually back up and then say going
back to work so this is the oh hello and
this is what happens when it's trapped
so these are some of the more distressed
sounds this is waking up and then this
is going back to sleep so and we have
some really fun facial expressions the
model that's on the market now has a
small LCD screen and not the LED matrix
glowing that we had envisioned but
talking about expressive objects i
wanted to share one of my students
projects from the upenn course that I
teach this is from a couple years ago
these students alone kinderman and John
Johnson decided that they wanted to do a
modern-day version of the swear jar so
I'll just like this one communicate with
them
[Music]
so the ideal design intent is it it
swings towards the person who said the
thing and then it pops the cork out of
them and it's cold so I think that's
interesting so then another part of this
so I've talked now about how the object
communicates outward and the other part
of this is the system understanding
human gesture so I do spend a lot of
time actually thinking about what how do
we gesture how do we use objects so this
next project you know and sometimes like
I said I challenge myself to use the
tools of the trade so that I understand
them in a visceral intuitive way this
next project was part of a residency
that I had done with a food designer and
we put our heads together and created
this project that is called the liq
astre so I said I really want to do some
stuff around capacitive sensing I need
really to like understand that and build
something and you know and she her focus
was really on
and food and we started working together
and we started putting sensors and
everything we could that was food and we
did a few workshops and had people come
over and eat marzipan that would you
know vibrate and have you know sounds
triggered what we wound up doing was
mapping the capacitive sensing to sound
and ultimately we decided to focus on
ice cream because ice cream is one of
those few foods that you have to eat
like this and we wound up creating this
installation that we could almost work
like it was an orchestra and we
collaborated with a musician named Aaron
Dyer and created this musical instrument
ice cream orchestra
[Music]
so it's pretty fun we did it a few
different venues where we to like put on
him he could say okay Kristin come up
rad and uh and you know and then I had a
much better understanding of capacitive
sensing it's actually also the project
that's gotten us like more attention and
like any other work we've done somehow
the licking ice cream the ice cream
orchestra there's a lab that I'm part of
at the University of Pennsylvania that
we called the experience lab at the X
lab so you know one of our tenets is
we've been working hard on creating
objects that are intuitive in the sense
that we use the natural gestures you
don't have to turn things on you don't
well you might have to turn this on but
you don't really have to engage in
interface other than playing with it the
way you would play with the analog
version so this is a system that is
mapping the block placement to a a
virtual shadow of that playing board and
the idea is we're still working this is
still in progress we're exploring
different ways that we abstract it
virtually whether or not we keep it
literal but this is an ongoing project
again around really just the intuitive
interaction our goal is that we want to
be able to have a child in the room and
know exactly what to do with the blocks
the next project i wanted to show is a
part of the interaction lab so the
barcelona branch of the interaction lab
did a series of projects that they
showcased at the barcelona mini maker
lab and what they did is they thought
about us as designers and what do what
might we use as objects that could
mediate the social interaction in
brainstorming sessions and so one of
them is a talking stick that knows when
you grasp it and will vibrate when it's
time to stop
which will encourage people who are more
shy to talk because they have the stick
and they know that they have the floor
and also discourage people who would
talk too long there's another one that
is around the thinking hats if any of
you are familiar with those theories the
one I wanted to show you is the echo so
the echo is something that actually just
sits quietly and listens but the idea
being that you could trigger a memory
from the day randomly and have that
trigger an idea in a nonlinear way so
here's a little bit about the echo
[Music]
so and these were all working prototypes
these are up on the smart interaction
lab com website this sex project is a
student project from my smart objects
course which I taught at SVA before
bringing it over to University of
Pennsylvania and there's a few
interesting things about this project
but I wanted to show it here
particularly for the use of gesture and
light is a smart desk light that
enhances the reading experience for
researchers students and book lovers it
brings features previously limited to
ebooks to all books however old they may
be
[Music]
definitions highlights let's welcome
text free encyclopedia definitions and
other data image scanning social
highlights from other users
[Music]
so um one of the most important things
that I have to do when teaching the
Smart Objects courses because my courses
are designed courses they are not
engineering courses but as you've heard
me say I know it's very important to
have our hands on the technology and to
understand it and experience it so what
we try to do is balance our prototypes
so what we're doing is prototyping the
experience so in some cases that means
building out so the the pieces that you
saw from the smart interaction lab we're
fully functional Arduino driven pieces
this piece does not make sense
necessarily to fully build out because
you would want to really explore all of
those nuances of gestures so what's
happening here is it's a scripted and
perfectly choreographed demo of how the
interface would work in a way that we
could have a conversation with our
reviewers and be able to really discuss
it in depth so one of the last things I
wanted to talk about was the importance
of designing for context so um the other
thing I do you know I started this talk
showing you robots that have eyeballs
and ears and do everything they're
really everything machines but what I
really focus on as a designer are
specific machines so how can we think
about what interaction what interface is
appropriate for a specific instance so
here is the apron alert this is also
from the interaction lab
you
bye
[Music]
so what's happening here is closing the
apron sends a message out that cooking
is starting and opening the apron
sends another message out that cooking
is done and you know what happened here
here's some lovin
is you know i sat down and said I bolide
like the labs you really let's do some
smart there's so much stuff around the
kitchen let's do some intersection
between the kitchen and Internet of
Things and instead of doing you know big
full-blown thing we just decided to
focus on this moment of how can we use
the technology to communicate to let
people know that cooking is done and
then right now so this is actually super
in the works and hasn't been completed
yet but I thought it was really
appropriate and talking about designing
for contacts so this is an
internet-connected coat rack that I'm
working on as part of my studio right
now and all it does is it knows when
you're standing in front of it when
you're standing in front of it it comes
to life and it greets you with
information about the weather so you
know what to take out with you and so it
gives you an animated version of you
know what the weather is now and a
couple of the conditions so it's sunny
and windy and 42 degrees although not
here in sunny California so what I've
been really focusing on lately are
natural materials natural interactions
and simple interactions so I'm going to
skip this project well I'll show to you
very quickly it's um this project is a
student project and it's called
cultivates by philip chang and sabrina
lee and they were looking at how we can
use a plant to communicate to bring a
couple closer together how can we have
it be the mediator in a long distance
relationship so they started out with
long distance relationship and then
eventually came to this moment of plant
so when one person is watering their
plant the other person knows that the
plant is getting cared for and gets a
reminder so it's about this reminder and
interchange that
is happening could potentially be
happening in a synchronous or
asynchronous way between two people who
have these paired plants and the health
of the plant will maybe map to the
health of the relationship so and to
wrap things up as you might have noticed
storytelling is really important in our
conversation during lunch we talked a
lot about storytelling and you know for
me it is the way that we get people
excited about what we're doing and we
bring it into context so they understand
how it fits into their lives so a few
years ago I was interested in desktop 3d
printing and how that was going to
change everyday life and so I did it a
bunch of research with experts from all
the 3d printer companies software
companies and saw that there are at
least seven different future visions we
might all have a 3d printer in our homes
we might you know go to a store there
might be 3d printing for food there
might be 3d printers on the moon and so
what I decided to do was build the story
for kids who are going to actually be
living in that future and illustrate
what the possible futures were the book
is called Leo the maker prints it's
published by maker media and it's a
story about a young woman who meets a
robot and the robot tells her all about
3d printing and in the book there are a
number of objects there's a URL at the
end so that as a reader is reading them
they can then go and find the 3d printer
and experience it themselves and
download the characters and the objects
from the book but you know my idea
behind it was really to communicate
these possible futures this idea around
customization 3d printed food local
store services so there's a different
robot and story for each of those
possible futures and then people all
over the world have been downloading
them so there's been this kind of
cyclical thing where then there's been
fan fiction happening around Mike so
then my sheep shows up in a story and
somebody post something on Thingiverse
or instagram
this is my favorite actually of the
fanfiction was this like nefarious thing
I was kind of waiting for the black
sheep to show up so but that's it I
think what we're going to do now is here
I'll put my for those of you who want my
contact information I think what we're
going to do now is a QA and then we're
going to do our discussion yeah okay
anyone have sorry I have any questions
or one discuss something or um yes but
so with the echo I understand its course
inspirational sounds from the
environment paperback how do you
determine like I doctor it sounds in the
event it would be like Maryland old with
a boring what's inspirational yeah no
that's a very good question and really
the vision was that it would be
something that you would have in the
meeting with you and that you would then
queue up random moments in the meeting
so that it would trigger ideas that
would not necessarily triggered when you
read the transcript read your notes as a
transcript of a meeting verbatim yes um
for the desk beacon that you designed to
have people on indicate whether you can
bother them people remember to score
three notes and they were using it yeah
you know um to be interesting so that's
also that was also a concept piece that
we didn't implement full-scale but we
did implement small experiments that
were equivalent to it around having
flags on our desks and no people forget
especially if you're like really in that
heads down moment and all you're
thinking about is how stressed you are
to get your work done you kind of forget
so that is I mean that's why we
prototype you know yes I went through
slides you had this three steps research
the idea prototype and then idiot idea
so do they and you're allowed to you go
through the research phase as well
because it seems like it's more about
the interactive experience
do you go through any research phase
with the students um when the students
do they do a research phase in that
particular class they do what I call
research light you know where they are
selecting an area and then they are
speaking to four or five people in order
to identify opportunities we do in our
program have a full course around need
finding and a full studio course around
problem around problems solutions
problem identifying problems and
exploring solutions so but in the one
semester course we do we do a research
light there and then when I work for
clients I have very different scopes and
I and I always if it's a large consumer
product we always want to do actually
quite a deep design research phase yes
um so I really great work and I think I
would love to hear what you so so much
of what you've been doing is really at
the leading edge of both social robotics
and the Internet of Things and I think
in the past couple of years we've seen
these things moving more from the
conceptual space and into more and more
products and so I'm wondering if you
could talk a little bit about you know
kind of how now maybe we have so many
smart Internet of Things devices and how
do we really think about these all
working together or how do you think our
responsibility as designers of these
products like we can all make a really
nice video that shows you know our
product in the context of its its use
but there's you know how do we think
about this and have thought some about
that yeah well I'm certainly have
thought um a lot about that and that's
smart when we are working in the lab we
always we always thought about that as
well and um you know to tell you the
truth it's kind of like a big ugly scene
out there right now where we have so
many things that are emerging and you
know the things that I get excited about
like how the vacuum cleaner talks to you
well if your vacuum cleaner and your
coffee
machine and your washing machine and
your broom and your coffee mug or
talking to you it's kind of this
cacophony right and they're all maybe
have their different signature languages
because you know manufacturer a has
their brand personality and manufacturer
be has their brand pastor personality
and you know the I think it's something
as designers we we absolutely need to be
extremely sensitive to and be thinking
about the environment as a landscape
rather than like the product yeah and
like we like to take pictures of the
product right on white like it's an
isolation it's this beautiful thing so
we definitely have to think about how
those things if they don't communicate
with one another how they kind of
respect one another and you know ideally
if they're communicating with one
another like how does one go in the
background and one come in the
foreground and it's a sort of big wicked
problem right now you know and the
ideals the ideal vision is you have one
manufacturer who's making all of those
things right and they're thinking about
this but then you leave the consumer
with this kind of monopoly if that's the
vision of only being able to choose from
this one manufacturer I don't have the
answer yes yeah so one of the things I
really like your videos and I'm
impressed at the lack of difference in
quality between the student videos and
the professional videos and ice
wondering what you guys doing your files
to teach people how to do the
storytelling around ideas yeah that's a
good question um and it's it's tricky
it's really hard in the one semester
course to require video output
admittedly I mean we definitely do a lot
of storyboarding I do a lot of showing
examples and deconstructing those
examples and talking about how the
storytelling happens and the ones from
SVA those students actually had a
prerequisite before my course that was
around prototyping
oh it's much trickier from my students
who take my class now it's an elective
and don't have the background so it's
actually something I would love to talk
more about because it's very very it's
very hard to do those videos and have
them come together tightly unbelievably
so the course at SVA had uh a section
around video prototyping that my
colleague clay wiedemann had taught as
well as sections around Arduino so you
know now at Penn I mean we definitely i
teach a theories and methods class and
video is part of what designers need to
get comfortable with yes thank you for
the presentation I noticed that in your
work there's a strong theme building a
standalone device for a specific purpose
and in cultivates this really makes
sense like you you can only communicate
with your significant other or whoever
through this binary beacon and that's
all the information you get from them
it's sort of romantic I was wondering
why an echo you chose to make that a
standalone device instead of perhaps
putting it in a smartphone or a
SmartWatch or something that may be more
ubiquitous and from a design perspective
flipped over decisions that right um and
I should say you know all of those the
cultivators is student work that I
coached and the echo is you know the
team from my lab so these projects are
all team projects I wanted to reinforce
them but in terms of how I lead those
projects the I'm very interested in
embodiment and I'm very interested in
you and I've dealt with this also on
professional products and to be honest
in the last five years so many projects
it's get to reach a wall well couldn't
we just do this with an app and there
there are a lot of reasons that you
might not want to do that the totem
projects you know are specifically
around pain points in the social dynamic
that may be less so the echo project but
you know something like the the Talking
Stick you could certainly have a timer
you could certainly do everything
digitally but the fact that you're
holding this object in your hand allows
you to have this this gesture that makes
you feel empowered so you know a lot of
it then again is around gesture a lot of
it is around giving importance to that
particular moment you know like the the
coat rack and your the moment that
you're actually selecting your coat
isn't is an important moment you know
and I wanted to kind of punctuated that
moment in the day by blowing out this
piece of information station from
whoever's interacting with the device oh
yeah there are few other things with
with smartphones in particular which is
that yet they are their personal devices
they're not shared devices their devices
where we I can i don't i don't think i
can tell you how many apps i have on my
phone i can't even find an app except
for searching for it now you know so it
all depends on how much weight and value
you want to give to that X particular
experience we're experimenting this with
a format a little bit you only have a
few minutes to try it out yeah but one
of the things i think that designers do
that i really wanted to be able to like
drive into this a little bit is critique
um i basically bring up something and i
talked about what something is saying so
when people hear critique we often hear
we think you're going to get something
like five stars or one story i like it i
hate it but actual designs nadeem could
take a lot of times they're trying to
read an object and see all the things
that are being said and try to
stand what that might mean and so I
asked Carla to kind of take us through
maybe a critique of a few products are
not ours or hers you know um so maybe
participate and help her honest and
let's see and maybe I will I'm going to
jump in I'm gonna jump around let's
start with this one how many of you are
familiar with this okay um so can you
tell me what Nick can you tell everybody
what it is go off it rolls off whatever
you have and starts rolling around the
room you have to get up chase after it
and pick it up and they don't push the
button to turn it off so um what who
likes this product okay I see you have a
head so what would you like about it yes
you ah but today some people really need
some active way to get out of bad the
sound just doesn't do it I can pick my
love and you're really needs this i know
i'm all about so you know one might say
that if you were if you were just if you
just sat down to design an alarm clock
you probably wouldn't come to this if
you just sat down to design a clock
right you'd probably come to something
might be square would certainly have the
numbers on it so you come to something
like this when you approach it with the
need of having to get out of bed at all
costs right so um you know what else can
we say about this product i I mean I
Wendy and I we talked about this one
because it's it's pretty interesting and
I
as robot designers it has this character
that it doesn't necessarily need to have
right like it has these giant wheel so
why might it have big wheels yeah well
for me my floor is pretty messy and so I
don't know if it's in thinking of my
encounter obstacles I don't know if
there's a correlation between people
have trouble getting out of fat people
have trouble keeping it did you say yeah
keeps it from breaking it does keep it
from breaking and there's there's also
just a semantic around you when you see
this in a catalog or at a store you know
that that's a thing that can roll around
because of the size of the wheels and
the positions of the wheels um any other
comments yeah so I own one of these I
think uh so the the thing that's
interesting about this is the time of
ownership in my opinion is thinking
about how someone will interact with
this throughout the life out of the
product and what happened to me was I
bought it I was like this is so cool I
totally got the whole character thing I
used it maybe for a couple of months
maybe not I don't know exactly and then
I stopped because it was too much
started to have better habits and I
would just wake up um oftentimes just
getting an alarm clock can help you do
that in your body will get into a rhythm
and soon I stopped using it it was
actually too much of a hassle and then
that full very fun interaction that you
had maybe the first couple of times
actually turns into a chore is actually
changed completely where this thing goes
from now that I'm looking at it and I
made it just the shading on this and I
go this foreboding
this faces when I first got it and so
this timeline of ownership is a
something that is was it really a she
it's not until I actually saw it again
right now I thought about this country
ownership coming cuz i still have an
incident right there somewhere and I'm
never going to turn it off yeah but I'll
keep I keep it haha as this like excited
I think that's something interesting i'm
not sure if that was entirely planned by
the designers to think about what does
the timeline right yeah and actually
when i was working on the needle project
i have a graph that actually kind of
lays out that timeline because we
thought a lot about how we really wanted
to amplify the personality and the sound
but you know after you hear certain
sounds every single day over and over
again you know that it kind of wears off
and what we plotted out was at the
beginning of the relationship you
actually have this infatuation because
especially with a robot vacuum cleaner
thats its novelty and its new and you're
excited i watched videos of people
bringing their roomba home and they
would actually post videos on you to as
if it were a member of the family like
we brought the room what's the baby
gonna think and like and um and so you
know we see that it that's an action
opportunity for us as designers right
especially the out-of-the-box experience
is when you need to kind of piggyback on
the excitement in order to do a little
tutorial as well so you can kind of
amplify the interactions and the sounds
and the expressions but then after what
you have to understand that like many
relationships it gets dull right towards
the end and and so you may want to be
quieter yeah i don't know if it's the
way that i traced this but i see a face
here to of course and i take issue with
poking eyes so I would I would I would
take a shoe with that
I asked it let's talk about this one so
this is less about form and maybe about
format but this gets back to your
question around you know standalone
devices right so there's this thing you
can do now where we can take for granted
that many of the people tore our
audience of people are going to use the
products have these extremely expensive
sophisticated inter inter phases in
their pockets so why might a designer
decide to do this and what might be the
decisions that lead to this yes
information so you have a history of
your birth control over time mmm right
and it could log it you could have a
screen and some memory on the blood
pressure monitor but then you would have
to dig that blood pressure monitor out
let's say you're at the doctor's office
right like the moments that you need
that information yes my phone is a very
personal device so it makes a lot of
intuitive sense that it has information
about me personally in my health so it
seems kind of intuitive
yes general I this is a very important
task like with if I'm sitting and I want
a measure my blood pressure I am very
concerned I need this information so
it's a for me it's okay to map it to
connect it up going but if it's a desk
about whether for example even though i
like my weather app I think this
connecting connecting it from the point
is good because once I hold my point and
want to do a lot of things like check my
notifications my email so it becomes a
very automatic task but in this case I
think it's convenient because you're
already doing that's very important
because of your focus so yeah you want
to give it focus that's interesting so
when when you would switch to the app
you would stay focused on that app you
wouldn't be multitasking right that's me
that's that's interesting yes right
you're not focusing on the products or
on your phone you're sort of going on
between yes little less feels us like a
single unit I think it is a medical
device and so the basic purposes like
you take the reading and then you want
to actually share it like you don't have
to you don't want like if it was a
standalone product not with the iphone
so it would take the reading but then
you have to type it reading and send it
to your doctor or someone lives but this
one can directly connect and then it can
take the reading and directly send the
notification that this is the actual
reading rather than like you typing it
out or making the mistake right so that
is the purpose of the medical device
maybe there's a different functional
aspect to this which is that when you
plug it into the phone it gets a little
bit of charge necessary to compute your
blood pressure and so you don't really
need batteries or anything to run that
Monica otherwise
yeah that's true yes right now and just
one minute I'm when I see that phone it
makes us that this is not just sent it
to the Internet at large this blood
pressure cook I like that you would have
this intermediate step for you piss out
of you know why I just want to fly the
stairs and it one of there is a quarter
for all time and since everyone just
going to take this again you claim it
and so I think in some ways having a
capable and having on your phone gives
you some personal control my ring of
information where a lot of things that
are just internet-connected I don't have
that yeah that's true that you may not
um think that's that's interesting that
it sort of gives you more control maybe
it's about having a more sophisticated
interface and more control yes Heather
fashions at some point because there's
no reason why it means to have a cable
to be able to do all these things sounds
of connecting with the phone but there's
like a lot of technology development
that needs to happen in terms of
life-long Howard right low energy knees
sucking devices but like a lot of the
projects you should have sort of been
pushing that for ya or you can have like
simple intelligence and little objects
and but I like that like there's a
really insane idea like the intimacy of
your data wow I was thinking before
about 20 like about like a like a
village mentality where's is a big city
where life it's not like everyone knows
each other business or everyone sort of
like Sam I thought I might notice it
yeah but yeah I don't know yes
interesting I mean the other thing
that's very it's a very important
decision for the designer to know that
this is going to be used in the home as
opposed to a small doctor's office or
like you're cutting out that part of the
market because the dot at the doctor's
office is going to be very inappropriate
let's say you want to be able to you
know have this be a shared device may I
suppose you could have like an iPod
Touch that's shared among people but it
sort of brings up that question
this interface can be changed that that
interface can be changed like whenever
we have great whereas if it on a
standalone product and then the
interface like once it is pushed to the
market to the consumer then it cannot be
changed right so it comes great sure
okay I don't know and then we run over
by eight minutes thank you guys I me in
painting Carla